Only by comparing the SNVs with the third option here do we achieve an IBS
score of 50%. So this is the only right answer here. So how did we figure
this out? Let's take a look at the first SNV. GC, CC. There's a
0.5 match. 50%, right? TG, TG is a 100%
match, GG, AG is a 50% match, and TT, AA is
a 0% match. If we average this, 0.5 plus 1 plus 0.5 is
2, and we divide it by the total number, which is 4. 2 over 4 is
one half, or 0.5, or 50%. Now, let's look at the
first option. GC, CC is 0.5, 0.5, 0, and then
0.5. This gives us 37.5%. So that's not right.
The second answer is low, only 25%. We have two SNVs that have a half match and
two SNVs that have no match at all. And the last answer is even lower,
at only 12.5%. Only one allele in one SNV matches,
at 50%. So the average is 12.5%